foreign
[Music]
copper Globe created in the early 1500s
the coast of Southeast Asia is marked
with a message that has since become
iconic
hear be dragons
though the words themselves were
actually quite rare the sentiment was
common among medieval European map
makers who often scrawled dragons and
sea monsters over Terra incognita blank
spots on the map for thousands of years
people all over the world had made both
functional maps showing trade routes
settlements topography water sources the
shapes of coastlines or written
directions and what are known as
cosmographies illustrating the earth and
its position in the cosmos often
including constellations gods and Mythic
locations
from the Middle Ages through the mid
17th century cartographers in Eurasia
and North Africa produced a slew of new
world maps with features from both these
Traditions often commissioned by rulers
and other powerful people these Maps
Were Meant to depict the world's
geography but not necessarily to be
useful for navigation
and given their makers incomplete
knowledge of the world they were really
hypotheses some of which have been
glaringly disproven
in medieval Europe the new Vogue began
with what were known as mapamundi many
of these veered closer to cosmographies
featuring The Garden of Eden or mythical
dragons
they all followed the same format
showing the world's land as one mass
divided roughly into the shape of a team
and surrounded by a ring of ocean
Islamic map makers also created world
maps in this format emphasizing
Geographic details over Fantastical
elements one of the earliest and most
accurate such Maps was created by Eben
Hawk Hall whose own travels informed his
map making
in 1154 the king of Sicily commissioned
Islamic map maker al-irisi to create the
tabula rajariana also known as a guide
to Pleasant Journeys into Faraway lands
this book of maps included a world map
based on idrisi's own travel and
interviews with other Traders and
travelers he correctly depicted the
world as a flattened sphere but thought
Europe Asia and North Africa wrapped all
the way around it
the da Ming Han Yi II was created in
China in 1389 on a piece of silk big
enough to fill an entire room though the
map makers had never been to Africa they
attempted to depict the continent based
on the accounts of the Traders who'd
been there
surprisingly this gave them enough
information to create a correctly shaped
portrayal of sub-Saharan Africa
beginning in the 15th century European
cartographers began to expand the scope
of their world maps as their explorers
traveled the world but not without
missteps in 1507 the German cartographer
Martin valsimula mapped the Americas as
a thin sliver of land where the East
Coast would be Spanish cartographers
took a stab at the western side of the
Americas based on accounts from an
expedition to the Baja Peninsula
unfortunately the Explorer's impressions
of the land LED them astray for over 100
years after Spanish Maps depicted the
island of California detached from the
rest of the continent
the Flemish cartographer gerardus
Mercator best known for his world map
also created a map of the
never-before-seen North Pole that was
published in 1595. Mercator speculated
that the North Pole prominently featured
the rupes Negra a giant magnetic rock
surrounded by a Whirlpool that explained
why all compasses Point North
even as Europeans built towards a
complete picture of the earth they
didn't entirely let go of the idea of
blank spots filled with Mythic beasts as
late as 1657 English scholar Peter Halen
lumped Australia together with Utopia
and Fairyland
but with the exception of the North Pole
these so-called Terra incognita weren't
really unknown at least not to the
people who lived there there weren't
really dragons anywhere on Earth but
there were people and cultures many of
them eradicated by those who put their
lands on world maps
even today every world map humans have
ever made is wrong that's right click
the video on the left to learn more
about bad Maps or click the video on the
right to learn the Epic tale of two
explorers racing to put the South Pole
on the map